This video is brought to you by glasses,
USA more about them in a bit,
but if you want glasses
up to 70% off retail,
follow the glasses USA
link in the description,
you'll love it,
or they'll give you your money back and
let's get into it.
Mohandas Gandhi started out as a scared,
painfully shy young man,
yet he was transformed by injustice,
to step beyond his insecurities to become
the 20th century's most influential
champion of social justice and the
standard bearer for nonviolent resistance.
Here's example of humility.
Courage and quiet.
Dignity has inspired millions and it's
been the catalyst for that change to a
better world.
In this week's biographics,
we discovered the inspirational
story of the great soul,
Mahatma Gandhi.
Okay.
Mahindras Comma.
John Gandy was born on October the
second 1869 in the coastal Indian town of
Poor Bandar.
He was the youngest of six children,
which included two half sisters
from his father's previous marriage.
Monjas.
His father,
[inaudible] was the Dijuan or
political leader of Paul Bandha.
His mother put Levi,
was deeply religious,
impressing strong Hindu
beliefs on her children.
Could.
I'm trans,
provided well for his family.
He lived in a three story house and
it's seven the Honduras was known by all
lists Mohammed.
He was especially devoted to his
mother who he considered to be a saint.
Her piety made a deep impression upon him.
When the boy was five his
father was appointed the
chief minister of the smaller
inland city of ranch
caught after two years.
The family that you joined him,
that one was a painfully shy Charles.
He kept to himself at school
when it's Besson's with Don,
he would run home in order to avoid
having to talk to any of his peers.
He was also a fearful child who
was terrified of many things,
but especially the dark.
He found his solace in books
which were if something,
if a constant companion when he was
just seven years of age and this was the
Hindu costume.
Mohan became engaged to Casta muck Hangi
[inaudible] who was a few months older
than him.
The arranged marriage was completed when
Mohan turned 13 the planning for the
lavish wedding ceremony and adjustment
to married life meant that he had to take
a year off from his schooling.
He was an average student at best,
though he tried hard
to please as teachers,
you have no interest in sports games or
social activities with any of his peers.
He did,
however,
make one friends around this time.
He wasn't Muslim boy by the name of
shake Mahtab Jake was old Zuarin's more
street smart than Mohammed.
It was also physically
larger and stronger than him.
He tried in Mohan about his frail
condition and it's holding this.
If he ate meat,
he would get to much bigger and stronger.
No,
this was strictly
against the Hindu belief,
especially.
Mohan met his friend in secret one day
and he had his first taste of meat even
though they caused him to vomit he to
eat it for the next year without letting
anyone else know.
During that period shakes hook
into a brothel and experience,
which was an embarrassing disaster
for the impressionable team.
Realizing that shake was
a bit of a bad influence.
He caught off association with him and
returns to a strict vegetarian diet.
Bowen's father calm John's died
when the boy was 16 years old.
The grief was compounded when Bon and
Costa was first child died less than a
week old.
The couple would go on to have four more
children with the first being born in
1880 8 million completed college at the
age of 18 and enrolled in some Aldous
college.
However,
he disliked the lecture style of
teaching and dropped out after only a few
months.
He had set his sights on becoming a lawyer
and eventually becoming a Duwan like
his father.
A family friends suggested that he should
go to England to study where it was
easier to pass the bar.
It was agreed that this would be the best
course of on the Shy Hindu boy was now
headed for the bright lights of London
on August the 10th 1880 8 million left
his family including his wife and his one
month old son [inaudible] and he
headed for Bombay where he bought it.
A ship that was bound for London.
Before leaving though he was something
to be the leader of his cost to warns him
that if he went to England,
he would be tempted to
break the rules of Hinduism.
He was told to either abandoned his plans,
will be excommunicated from the cost.
Gandhi accepted this consequence
and he continued upon his way.
Fitting into Western culture though was
that it was a shock to the 18 year olds,
everything.
It was so different,
so what he had known back in India,
it's still,
he did his best to fit
in buying a fine suit,
complete with a leather gloves,
top hat and Silvertips cane.
He also paid for lessons and
elocution manners and dumps.
His biggest challenge was
with regard to his diet.
He had vowed to his mother that
he was not going to eat meat,
but he was finding it very difficult
to find restaurants that cater to
vegetarians.
His chronic shyness prevented
him from requesting alternatives,
do what was on offer.
That finally though you found a
vegetarian restaurants along with a whole
community of vegetarians and it was at
this point so that he joins the nuns and
vegetarian society.
Just wait as difficulties with
fitting into London in life.
Gandhi did well academically.
He passed his law exams in June of 1891
his friends at the vegetarian society,
they held a celebrator
evening and is on it.
When it came time to give a speech.
However,
Mohan was so nervous that he
simply rose and Tony said,
thank you.
Okay
on is returned to India.
Mohan was met at Bombay harbor by his
older brother who bought some terrible
news,
his mother,
but Levi had died in his absence moons.
Grief was compounded with the
consequences of his overseas foray.
He was now disfellowshipped from his cost
in order to please his family members.
He agreed to bathe in a sacred river
in order to wash away the sins of
England's.
This precipitated his
reentry into the cost going.
Z books for work is a lawyer in Bombay.
However,
his chronic shyness was still preventing
him from making any advancements.
He recalls how he fell is presenting his
first case before the court saying my
head was reeling and it felt as if
the whole court was doing likewise.
He retreats it to the nes
imposing town of Raj Carlton,
just stablish to a small law office that
shortly thereafter he received an offer
from the much and two had
been a friend of his father.
This man was now based in South Africa
and he needed a lawyer to help with the
court case.
The year long job was often
to Gandhi and he accepted it.
Just finished recently
becoming a father again.
He kept his wife and two young sons
under the camera of his brother and he
headed off a Durban South Africa in April
of 1893 officer settling into his new
surroundings,
guns.
He took the trains,
Pretoria where the court
case was to be tried.
He purchased a first cost ticket.
However,
on one of the stops the
European men bolted,
the car that he was in,
the men resented seeing an Indian and
first costs and left to find the train
conductor.
The two men returned and has gone.
D was wanting to go down
to the third class section.
God's.
He showed them his fitness costs
tickets and refuse to move or to that's
trained.
Security was cooled and gum
dia was kicked off the train.
He had to go to the rest of the
way in a horse drawn carriage.
However,
the white passengers of that carriage,
they refuse to lessen Indians it inside
with them and he was made to sit on the
outside foot board.
He lays it recalls.
The insult was more than I could bat.
This was the watershed experience of my
hundred Gandhi's life as if by miracle
he shook off his timid nature and stepped
forward as a leader of the oppressed.
When he arrived in Pretoria,
he called a meeting of the
Indian community and gave
the funniest speech of his
life cooling for the Indians
to stand up for their rights.
Once his work on the
court case was completed,
Gandhi decided to stay and continue
to fight the Indian rights.
In 1894 he established the natal Indian
Congress to give Indians a political
voice.
He established himself as a leader in
the local community giving free legal
advice and offering support.
In 1896 off to three
years in South Africa.
Gandhi,
writtens India to connect his family.
It returned with his wife and two sons
who are now aged nine and five along with
a nephew.
Gandhi demanded that his family,
they dress as Europeans and eat with
knives and forks as it was the way with
Indians in South Africa.
This goal tension within his family.
Still two more songs were added to
the family and the coming years.
When the bow Walbro accounts
in 1899 Gandhi fell to this.
If the Indian supported the government,
they would be rewarded
with that or treatments.
He organized an Indian ambulance corps
who are a valuable asset to the army,
but the loyalty,
it wins unrewarded with the
harsh treatment continuing
during this time gone.
D develops the life philosophy,
which was to going in for
the remainder of his days.
They called it [inaudible],
which means devotion to the truth.
The three core tenants of the
belief where noncooperation,
nonviolence and non possession.
In 1906 the South African province of
Transvaal enacted a law that required all
Indians to register and
be given identity cards.
The police were allowed to stop and
demand their registration as any time.
No other group have this requirement.
Guns he advocated the use of
saw Takahata counsel the law.
He told people not to register.
As a result,
he ends.
Many others were thrown in jail,
but Gandhi taught that righteous
imprisonments was an honorable thing.
The concept of Satyagraha took hold
and Gandia established a number of
cytochromes settlements.
The people in the settlements,
they practiced non possession,
living a simple and austere life guns.
He also organized a large coal miners'
strike the men practice noncooperation by
refusing to work and nonviolence by
refusing to react when they were attacked
spinal authorities.
In July of 1914 the South
African government passed
the Indian really fact which
wins some way to righting the wrongs
that had been heaped upon the Indian
community.
The 20 years of struggle that
Gandhi had put into the cause.
We're largely responsible for these
changes and after this he was ready to
return to India,
bringing his philosophy with him.
And do you know what else he
brought back to India with him?
His famous glosses?
Yes,
I absolutely just did that.
Welcome to an unexpected Abrie brought
to you by glasses USA and you can,
there's a gandy wish they existed back
when he wold glosses because fat just
excellent.
These ones that could,
would les,
and I've also got two others that
you see me wearing from time to time.
There's one this,
there's also a bigger pair,
which I don't have all
my little table here,
but you can also get them in
a whole bunch of other styles.
They've got a huge range.
Some 4,000 options are available.
Then,
Hey,
they've also got designer sunglasses.
You saw me wearing these at
the beginning of the video.
Now this isn't actually
on the talking points,
but I believe what is perhaps
the biggest testament,
the glasses USA,
is that this is my second
pair of sunglasses from them.
A few months ago,
I lost a power while I was
on holiday and by lost,
I mean I literally flushed them
down the toilet by accident.
I really couldn't be making this stuff
up and I had such a good experience with
glasses USA that I just went
on the Internet and bought
the same identical path.
They already had my prescription.
I just plugged it in
and I bought a new pair.
That's exactly the same.
I think that really says a
lot about how great it is.
You can also try them on online with a
virtual mirror and the best thing of all,
it's super affordable glasses USA.
They cut out the middleman giving you
prescription glasses and up to 70% off
retail and frames and lenses.
They start at just $30 plus a seat by
quality lenses that every good as bit as
my old glasses that I had ages ago.
They were overpriced and just not
as good and if you're not happy,
you can just send them back.
There's a hundred percent
money back guarantee.
You can check out glasses,
usa.com in the link below and get
a special deal on your first pair.
Let's get back to Gandhi
and his non glasses.
USA specs.
Ooh,
gums or you were surprised to receive
a hero's welcome back to India.
His efforts on behalf of South African
Indians had been well reported over the
years and Indian poet referred to him
as Mahatma meaning great souls and the
names are cold as a sign of the shy
young man who had left in 1893 written
didn't 1915 as a leader and he was a
leader with a mission and that of course
was Indian self rule.
Gandhi also challenged his own people
to look at the unfair treatments within
their own culture.
He challenged the cost system and
especially the terrible treatments of the
lowest class known as the untouchables.
He established a said Gog Raha settlements
in which the people spun yarn and
farmed free trees gone.
The accepted on touchables into this
community and taught the local peasants
proper hygiene and encouraged factory
workers to wage peaceful strikes against
the unfair working conditions.
Despite his belief in nonviolence gone.
D did support the British war
effort during World War One.
The wars ends,
the government Pasternack's making it
illegal for any group to organize and
oppositions and the government's gone.
Z equals for a mass strikes at
protest the Lawrence for one day,
the whole of India came to a standstill.
It was clear evidence of
the power there's gone.
Dee was able to wield yes when reports
filtered in that some Indians had
resorted to violence on the
day of peaceful protest.
He was bitterly disappointed.
He knew at that point
that as people as a whole,
we're not ready for sat gog Gra now the
British were concerned that there would
be further outbreaks of violence.
And so a law was passed banning any
gatherings of Indians in the city of
Amritsar.
One of the places where von instead of
cut the following day was the beginning
of the religious new year.
And about 10,000 people
gathered in the town square.
They have not yet how the news of
the band as they were a piece for the
listening to a speech 90
soldiers and to Almond,
cause 10.
Dot.
They blocked off the only
exit and proceeded to father
weapons into the unarmed
crowd of men,
women and children.
379 people were killed that day with
more than a thousand words being wounded.
In 1920 you're Ganti became the leader
of the Indian national congress.
Advocating is nonviolent resistance
and instituting strikes and boycotts to
bring pressure on the system gone and
he told the people to boycott of British
cloth and spin their own IV out to spend
time spinning every day and took to
wearing clothing made of hand spun cloth.
He made the spinning wheel and
national symbol of Indian independence.
Goldade traveled throughout the massive
countryside going mostly on foot.
He lives with the downtrodden in their
makeshift to dwellings and listened to
their problems.
To them.
He was a saintly figure as
they refer to him as babble,
meaning father.
In March 90 22 guards,
he was arrested for sedition.
The trial gave him the platform to expound
upon the unfair treatment of Indians
and his refusal to
cooperate with unjust laws.
These in guilty,
he was sentenced to six years in prison.
Mints Gone d though he was not deterred
using his time of confinement of read
and study off two years he was released.
His focus was now on creating
harmony between induce and Muslims.
For centuries,
the two groups had been at loggerheads
with one another with Vaughn and clashes
often breaking out.
Gandhi saw that independence would be
impossible without unity and he was
determined to bring these
two groups together.
Gandhi undertook a hunger fast as a
tool to bring the Hindus and the Muslims
together for three weeks.
He only drank water as they're
bad people grew weaker by the day.
The Hindus and Muslims finally agreed to
put aside their differences in order to
stop suffering.
Okay.
On march the 12th 1930 guarantee began
a month long track from his Ashram and
under batch to the seed.
Hundreds and then thousands of followers
of all religions and costs is joins him
along the way.
News of the march.
If fill papers around the world,
the British had long imposed a law
making it illegal for anyone to make salt
from seawater in India.
As a result,
they were able to make huge
profits from their salt tax.
24 days after setting out
on his march to the sea,
Gandy Arrive Dondhi on
the Gulf coast of Cambay.
The following morning,
Gandhi walked out into the sea
water to bathe on Ezra town.
He picks up a handful of salts
in defiance of the salt act.
This act was a signal for his countryman
and up and down India's coastline.
Thousands of others began collecting
seawater in order to make and sell salt.
Many were arrested,
including Gandhi,
who was thrown in prison
for a second time.
You had the British could not silence.
Mahatma officials now realize that
this man held a powerful sway over the
masses.
He simply could not be ignored any longer.
The more the British government,
both in India and at home were being
pressured by other governments to release
Gandhi from jail.
Finally the British Viceroy in India.
Daughter when met with Gandhi
after lengthy discussion,
they came to a truce,
gone.
D would cool off the demonstrations.
The prisoners would will be released and
Indians would be allowed to make their
own salts.
In 1931 Gandhi traveled to London to
represent the Indian national congress as
an international round table conference.
He called for Indian
independence from Britain.
You can pinned,
done that.
We run
rather than mixed with the other
delegates in their five star hotels gone.
The stayed with an old friend and spent
his days walking around the slums,
dressed in his traditional whom spawn
Cottey and his sandals he will is by now
the famous international figure runs.
Newsreels of his visits were shown in
movie theaters all around the world.
Surely after returning to India,
Gandhi was again arrested for
inciting civil disobedience.
While he was in prison,
the British government passed a law that
discriminated against the untouchables
and court proceedings.
Gonzi was infuriated,
doesn't announce that he would not eat
until this law was revoked fairing,
that his death would create a martyrdom
that would doom them in the eyes of the
welds.
The authorities caved in.
The law was rescinded when
Britain declared war on Germany.
In 1939 Gandhi told the authorities that
Indians would only join the war fs if
they were promised their independence.
Three years later,
he started a quit India
movement as always,
the plans for the
campaign to be nonviolent,
especially things soon got out of hands
and riots broke out across the country.
The authorities blamed
Gandhians one small,
he was thrown in jail.
His beloved wife,
Christa,
was also imprisoned at this time and age.
She soon became ill,
dying in custody.
On February the 22nd 1944
following his wife's death,
Gandhi grew weak with malaria.
The authorities agreed to release him
then may of 1944 and he went to Bombay to
recover and recuperate
the end of World War II.
Saw great person on its
knees though Victoria,
since it's spent exorbitant amounts in
the war efforts and now no longer have
the results,
is to maintain its role within India
with little choice in the massive person
offered India its independence.
It was the grand victory that Gandhi
had been fighting for for the past 30
years.
Even though the nation was
now free to rule itself,
India was still plagues with deep division
between Hindus and most of them's the
only solution seemed to be to
divide the country up and do Hindu,
India and most of them Pakistan.
This was a move that was greatly
displeasing to Gandhi who loaned the unity
between these two groups.
In the weeks following
the creation of Pakistan,
there were violence clashes
between Muslims and Hindus
up and down the country.
Massek as a could throughout 1947 with
both sides being equally responsible for
the bloodshed.
Hundreds of thousands of people died and
there were riots in most of the major
cities.
On January the 13th of 1948 the 78 year
old gone day began the fost in order to
get the madness to stop.
He was so despondent that he
refused to even drink water.
Despite the physical pain that he was in.
He still lead a pram.
Meeting from his bet is wads were
broadcast around the entire country.
Five days into his fost.
Muslim and Hindu leaders
agreed to a piece of court.
However,
Gandhi was still very concerned about
the direction the fledgling nation was
taking.
The new prime minister Jawaharlal Nehru
was constantly at odds with his deputy
Vallabhbhai Patel and gone.
Z counseled both men to make peace.
On January the 30th 1948 he was in a
meeting with Patel just after 5:00 PM he
came out into the gods and a bill,
a house in Delhi to offer prowess
weakened from his recent Fasti,
leans on two of his followers for support
as he walks a crowd of some 500 people
were waiting to greet him as he made his
way to the platform or Hindu extremist
Angus Gandhi's leniency towards
the Muslims snapped forward.
He bowed before the Mahatma and then
pulled out a pistol and fired three shots
and succession of pointblank
range within half an hour.
The last breath of life.
It seeped out of his body and
the great soul with no more.
When he had the news of Mahatmas death,
the prime minister stated the light
has gone out of our lives and there is
darkness everywhere.
Hundreds.
Gandhi was a light,
not just to the people of India,
but those of the entire wells.
His funeral procession through the streets
of Delhi was attended by more than 2
million people and years after his death,
countless of the millions,
including a young Baptist minister
from Georgia named Martin Luther King,
would find inspiration in
his words and in his legacy.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did do give us a like below,
and don't forget to subscribe.
Also check out glasses USA.
It's just a great deal.
You'll find a link in
the description below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.